welcome back it is Johnny and Yusef from
propane fitness hello today we are going
to talk about relationships 103 we have
done two very successful episodes that I
think have helped a lot of people or at
the very least helped us understand our
own stunts and relationshi have a
relationship but it's ended a
relationship ended the relationship so I
got a message from someone I want to say
who careful I got a message from a girl
on Twitter saying that after she watched
one of the relationships podcasts she
decided to finish a relationship she'd
been unhappy in for a long time and was
now four weeks Hensen feeling liberated
and better for it so congratulations
Instagram funnel exactly so today we're
actually speaking of ending
relationships we're getting to the the
darker parts I think of relationships
we're going to talk about cheating how
to get over someone and how to end
relationships it's quite a quite a murky
world this one isn't it we're down into
the depths now or all of the fish you've
got long teeth and they've got those
little hotel open their teeth think
about this yeah and one of the worst
things is that all of us have got really
terrible stories of ours brilliant /
terrible however you would like to look
at it indeed yeah so yeah I think we
left off last time kind of trying to
work out how to establish a good
relationship and move it forward but
obviously doesn't matter how well you
try and start things off inevitably
relationships do sometimes go awry and
certainly in my experience in
relationships the beginning of for me
the first realization that there's
something wrong is when sexual interest
starts to wane so for me that's like the
the first warning signal like as soon as
that starts on my man like I'm not being
interested I'm not being challenged I'm
not being and there's not as bothered I
would say when sexual interest starts to
wane
that's the sugary coating to the
relationship and it reveals any
underlying malformations with the way
that you've come together and it makes
it more obvious because there's no
longer any sugar coating to make that
better and there's two themes that you
mentioned in one or two about when you
meet someone and you have slightly
misaligned values and as you grow
together those trajectories will move
further and further apart and when they
get to breaking point and there's a
natural progression which is breaking up
and the other thing was about tolerating
things or what was the word you use like
keeping someone right or yeah drawing
lines in the Sun yeah having having
those boundaries and if you don't set
them early on over time because the
sugar coating starts to dissolve yeah
yeah exactly that's kind of right isn't
it over you get kind of like compounding
interest on differences between the two
of you or it's like the trajectory of a
rocket ship like if you're one percent
off at the start by the time you get to
the moon you're actually like a hundred
thousand miles apart from each other and
it's like you're holding a rope and you
both just start walking in the desert
yeah okay stretchy rope let's say long
long long long it's a nasty yeah and you
both just start walking together you
think you're walking parallel that over
time you start realizing they're both
walking like that drifting apart and
then eventually the Rope pulls more and
more and more and you either allow it to
pull yourselves together and you realign
your values together or you carry on
stubbornly go in your own way until it's
not all you've and you and not see
someone else who's holding a bit a rope
and think one see a bit of that robot or
and this one that and then before you
know it you've got a hold of five bits
of rope well that's when you are trying
hold on the one you just
and then hoping they don't notice but
they can see that you're holding on to
two ropes and then you got one in your
mouth and then you've got like I don't
think we need to talk about what we've
blown a month yes yet researchers work
for that's a available on a members-only
website - and what not to put in your
mouth quite certain requirements for
that exactly so yeah I think should we
start with cheating in a relationship
because we've still got the relationship
at this point
mm-hmm oh this is imaginary meet this
imaginary relationship that's had a
million different time I should only say
then like if you watched if you're
watching this and you haven't seen 101
and 102 these move in chronological
order are from God's sake you're the
hell I mean why are you watching 103
before you've watched one or two another
one it's cousin threes got better
stuffing as I always do that I was
watching I skipped ahead a free iPhone X
not an iPhone one how many fair enough
for whatever so cheating in a
relationship a couple of things that I'd
like to kind of mention straight off is
that the certainly been times where I've
been my infidelities in relationships
haven't been massive but there have been
that they've existed and one of the main
reasons that I've done it I think is to
kind of protect myself
I've kidded myself into believing that
if I cheat in a relationship that
somehow gives me some sort of power or
if I've got some insecurities about the
way that the other person feels about me
it almost comforts me and kind of pads
those out gives it an artificial sense
of inflation where I'm not as bothered
like it's I've like I've slept with
someone else so I'm not really that
asked but that all that you doing there
is you're just papering over cracks of a
problem which you're going to get worse
and in fact actually just driving a
wedge into them because if you're
concerned about how you feel about
someone sleeping with someone else is a
pretty sure fire way it's beginning - so
are you saying cheating you whenever you
have cheated it's been a political move
or is it just that it's unconscious
behavior that then as you think about it
it's like ah maybe I did that so that I
can distance myself from it well oh yeah
I think in retrospect I'm not really too
sure at the time
it's quite so primal and tits na yeah
Fitz and shagging enough but yeah I
think it feels like an insurance policy
somehow against being hurt by this
interesting Oh Toby if you it makes
sense like yeah emotionally strong
people before yes I've know cheated on
someone I have okay so I never viewed it
in the way that you viewed it that feels
very like a step away from the situation
it's like here's a situation happening
I'm gonna go to another room and think
about it and then come back in and make
a decision my I feel like mine was
always like this this situations kind of
doesn't feel as good as it used to so
I'm looking for the next one if that
makes sense
oh so you were prospecting I think so
okay so that's the difference
observation that isn't it that's like
I'm unhappy in this but I'm not doing it
as an insurance policy to feel better
about this relationship I'm just looking
for a new rope to hold so I think
actually that's I think the reason why
most people cheat is that they believe
that the sugary coating is the the range
to chase yeah and so I got I also think
that every relationship has a fixed
trajectory so like there's this you'll
encounter the same problems now like in
the relationship you're in now and then
as you will and the one that you move
into you by cheating assuming that most
people like they're married for example
they cheat on their partner and then end
up in a relationship the person cheated
on thinking that they will never
experience the problems that they had
with that person but actually they're
just starting again and in two years
probably on the worst premise as well
because you then it's not a relationship
on the prayer well so the one way to
know for sure that the person that
you're with will cheat on you how's the
capacity to cheat is because you met
them by cheating on so on I know that
you think it doesn't mean there's a mean
flowing around that says if he cheats
with you he'll cheat on you mmm well
like that I don't think that's an unfair
thing to say as well like pasta havior
is you're looking obviously active
[ __ ] [ __ ] obviously yeah hmm so yeah
I have a little different no I've
changed so that's that though I think um
having cheated on someone before I now
realize how just utterly pointless it is
like it is it is it is hyperbolic
discounting at its at its biggest most
every Sidious form I've got one where is
it my foot ah thanks Johnny is it going
yeah great
I'm glad that we featured that so yeah
the hyperbolic discounting think it's
from 101 and you mentioned it in that so
you need to go back and watch it yet I
haven't say um so I totally agree
there's kind of like a product life
cycle exactly and then you've gone
you've got like intro growth maturity
and then as it begins to tail off all
that you're doing is just saga yeah and
actually I think the some of the the
best parts of relationship are accessed
only after you've gone through that
period of time through the the lull and
yeah because it's a low if you choose it
to be alone it's a lot of you think like
I'm so back into my analogies of like
shooting a relationship as an asset like
people think that a relationship happens
to them and then when the relationship
stopped working they think I well the
relationships stopped working so I need
to go and find a new one rather than the
relationship start working why don't i
invest more time in the relationship to
try and make this relationship better
it's like you've gone you put all this
work in finding this person building
their relationship with them having all
these experiences with them then as soon
as something like sexual interests or or
whatever it goes a lot of people myself
included
at one point have gone [ __ ] this I'm off
rather than actually why don't I just
double down on this and see if I can fix
the problem it's like a it's like a
startup cost or a fixed overhead to a
relationship isn't yeah to the beginning
everybody needs to do the same things
you need to meet the parents you need to
work out where they live you need to
work out their schedule you need to try
and align yours with theirs and there is
a Illustrated headache it mean is it a
night melt
it's a bloody
so have to repeat that just for the sake
of novelty is a bit so we got criticized
last time for I think it was your
analogy of the second-hand car market in
relationships and actually this time in
fact it's entirely accurate well I will
fight to the death anyone who thinks
that that's it your commodifying women
it's like no you have not met or
assuming yeah I'm talking about though
you're talking about men and works in
both directions so that in all
directions all directions yeah not it's
not my directional yeah that put me in a
box room that was videos a Dean that
over for anyone who's listening you'll
notice there is a there is a discrepancy
about whether video man Dean is called
video man Dean or video guy Dean so
we've decided that we're now non-binary
and when name fluid so no preferred
pronoun Dean no yes with your personal
videos so this this this curve I feel
like you're making right at I if you
were to buy a decent car to begin with
yeah
now and your plan is to keep it for 50
years you would spend some time looking
for a good car you can get a cheap
rubbish one yep you would then invest in
it you treat it well so that in 30 years
time or 50 years time it becomes a
vintage car or becomes a classic car
rather than if you've got a rubbish one
that has no prospect of becoming a
classic car in the future mmm-hmm then
yeah you're gonna have to keep hopping
between cars and finding you that I use
my shoe analogy know that's time I
remember losing the shoe another day I'm
gonna [ __ ] the to analogy I'm gonna get
someone's gonna get upset again so
imagine if I said this is very like very
Tim Ferriss so imagine you're going
you're going travelling single backpack
and you can take with you one pair of
shoes and that pair of shoes has to be
comfortable to walk in yeah it has to be
appropriate for if you smartly dress
yeah I feel to go the gym in in them
like you would pick a [ __ ] good pair
of shoes like you would spend a lot of
time wearing at the prison cost of all
they're from pairs of shoes in
relationships what a lot of people do is
see the flimsy high heel and think
I want to buy them and they look nice
they work in one specific area of your
life or they may be mapped around
specific situation of one side of your
personality but actually when you want
to go for a walk on Sunday morning
they're never gonna work or a pair of
lifters yes I saw a video the day of a
guy walking come where was he was just
like walking on the street and a pair of
course shoes felt like that's a man he
bought the wrong pair of shoes he bought
the wrong shoes I bet his relationships
a terrible is yeah awful in relation so
like in the same amount like if you
don't fit for purpose yeah you've got
any buying these pairs that this pair of
shoes like you're investing in this
situation that like you're gonna be with
that person on holiday like in the house
and there's nothing to do in all these
different situations so you better make
sure that if they say that's by the
Volvo isn't it knowing that it's gonna
last you mmm so to to going all over the
turbo it's a nice exhausts it's chilly
on season 12 isn't it so the the
cheating side of things why do you think
people cheat in relationships why do you
think men cheat first I think it's the
belief that novelty will cure the
problem that they're experiencing on the
feeling that they're experiencing
whether that is lack of connection like
lack of engagement feeling unhappy with
the person so like something happens in
the relationship but not the existing
novelty by definition was after there's
no longer novel and we are in a society
whereby you are constantly aware of
other options in relationships so
walking down the street on Instagram
Facebook whatever like this hinder every
tip while you're in a more direct sense
but even if you're not in like a dating
market you're still presented with
window shopping hundreds and hundreds of
different people who were single who
were sort of advertising that life as it
were on social media and so to to try
and tell yourself whether this is in a
relationship or or anything for that
matter like the decision I've made is
the best decision and I'm happy for I'm
happy with that and no alternative is
possibly better when you are in a
situation that you are feeling doubtful
of and and it's the so the shines gone
off it and suddenly as an opportunity
placed in front of you and you think
that novelty that is appealing
you people that tend to make a
short-term decision I think are
signalling again off hotness rather than
beauty to a degree as well yeah I
remember the analogy if you have one or
two people are using that as a gauge of
well this is potentially more beautiful
because there's a novelty bias and a
recency bias as well and all of the
other all the other cognitive biases
early so so hot
um like some Jimmy Choos beautiful is
like like a nice pair of Nana's or like
the could be worn in loads of different
situation together like they're really
nice but they're not quite as glitzy yep
I gotta why do you think let me pair of
Merrill's yeah there probably would be
some cat boots yeah why do you think
women cheat use it so there's there's a
few psychologists that have formalized
what Johnny has just said there which is
the stereotype that men will treat for
ochite for physical of sexual novelty
and women cheat because they feel
unloved and that the primary driver of
men's motivation in a relationship is
respect and for women it's love and if
they don't feel like they're receiving
that respective thing then they'll start
to be unhappy in the relationship and
want to leave there's an interesting
study which looks at asking people who
are in partnerships how what would be
worse for you if your partner was having
great sex with someone else or if your
partner was deeply in love with someone
else it's like what on one side it was
they didn't care about them but were
having good sex yeah and on the other
side didn't ever touch them but sent
very meaningful messages and cared about
them deeply yeah exactly so there's two
kind of opposites on the spectrum and
men would always say or in general would
say I prefer if my partner is deeply in
love with someone else but didn't touch
them and women would prefer the opposite
so that's quite interesting with the way
that we're wired as we said okay what's
that perfect so men would prefer if
their partner was in love with someone
else rather than if they were having
great sex with someone else but it was
meaningless I think that just hugs but I
really can't decide really I think I
would
I'm probably part of that stereotype you
prefer that they were in love
yeah even though it's illogical because
that's harder to remedy yeah in this
situation right now it's easy for me to
it's easy for me to rationalize but the
juvenile ego inside of me I know how
visceral and how stomach punching is
when you don't feel like you're good
enough and it's there's nothing that you
can do to stop to want that feeling to
just [ __ ] the visceral like Aubrey
Marcus was talking about when his wife
first has sex with someone else and he
started this polyamorous relationship
that he spent a lot of the time like dry
retching on all fours just like yeah
great mulberry insane great one
so [ __ ] annoying Boulton broth on the
morning they enjoy that love you wife
wife getting leather doll over by some
twenty one-year-old from Austin Texas
your sense of Campbell trying to be
pretty walking on bag rats [ __ ] off or
writing a book that's really misleading
and lures you in to begin with thinking
actually what worry this might be all
right and then you got about twenty
pages
this is he's throwing axes a plank of
wood in the [ __ ] garden it no it is
actually it took it yeah please come on
over it so yeah I think both of those
analyses are very accurate
let's say for me it was kind of like a
protectionist strategy like if I had if
I a this is a hedge but it wasn't
because I never had a lot of the time I
never had any intention of going off
with one of the other girls right what I
was doing was I was using it to protect
my own insecurities about not about
concerns about the partner in my
relationship so it was like if I've
cheated then at least I've cheat it's
the got in that first is it prisoner's
dilemma yeah it's like to steal steal a
split yeah exactly still in first two
you they con yeah you can't you can't
steal as much as I've stolen because
I've stolen thirty limits your
case scenario which is it's a huge
fallacy it's just not true like you
think that it's going to somehow hurt
less but the difference is you've robbed
yourself of the one thing that you could
have held onto which is the fact that
you could have been virtuous hmm like
there is nothing there's no sympathy for
anyone in a relationship if you find out
that both partners have cheated on each
other mmm well then you just in a mess
on me the relationships ruined wants the
first partners cheated absolutely really
like once that's done it's especially if
it's if it's withheld from the partner
yeah I know some people are always
brought was closer together because then
we became honest but anyone anyone who
saves that you've managed to make a
partnership work because one of you is
cheated on the other one is shutting
[ __ ] yeah it's it's rationalizing it to
feel better about the fourth offset
honestly like it's yeah you're trying to
you're kidding yourself
you're absolutely kidding you cannot you
could get into with the mop mop mark you
at mockery Oprah's good
so sex at dawn that but I haven't read
it yeah because that's he he's a big
believer in like polyamory and monogamy
is anyone read who's read sex at dawn
it's completely shifted that perspective
on polyamory really like oh my god like
I'm never getting married and honestly I
read it bollocks let's look at it from
very very briefly I've done two podcasts
with evolutionary psychologist recently
I'll lay a couple of a couple of points
on you two guys later Manas female women
own you know female women female women
female female women that's a joke from
relationships 101 if you haven't a just
a joke that I can't even remember so I
don't feel bad if you don't like I this
integration [ __ ] when I want you were
you were here I was here you existed
anyway my meetings are so I'm female
female humans they don't have visual
ovulation
they digital ovulation is that right
what would it be if like you can't see
when a woman's on heat OS yeah this
subtle signs right yeah we pick up on it
yeah but mostly you have it's not the
same as like a dog but
gives off pheromones okay so anyway then
there is the fact that sex is a very
long process for humans compared with
other animals it's very long a very long
process and basically all of the things
it would appear that human sex has
evolved to encourage his pair bonding
that it requires the man to it's not
that easy to get pregnant
like you don't know what time if the
month it is for her so you need to
continue to have sex sex lasts for a
while and feels relatively good compared
with some other animals as well and what
this leads to is consistent sex
consistent long pleasurable sex and
what's the outcome of that pair bonding
okay you have a greater sense of bond
between the male and female okay there's
a couple of things about the size of
testicles are supposed to relate to how
promiscuous the females are because the
bigger the testicles the most semen
there is to wash out the man before you
and that's straight from the mouths of
Professor William von Hippel something
similar where like the blonde shape of
the penis so there's are the glans of
the penis
yeah he's shaped has that the corona the
ridge mm-hm so that it can serve a cume
yet so he's he's seen the penis there's
a penis plunger video which video
mantain if he can make it work we'll be
back the bed anyway you're putting that
you tube holding baby I'm so a corona
exists to scoop other men Superman
creates a vacuum that pulls over semen
assuming you've looked you having a
woman who's just have sex with someone
else
assuming you are I think there's a
technical term for that is porridge
stirring pour it okay porridge stirring
is that yeah the clinical term
apparently
right that's how it goes lovely image um
so we doing it wrong there if that's
what you're supposed to do yeah use a
big two hands yeah [ __ ] they're getting
that so yeah I think the the
evolutionary justification for cheating
aside the orgasm as well the
contractions push the semen up into the
uterus is all right yeah so up into the
ovaries so like the the contractions so
if you if you make a woman orgasm during
sex supposedly that is two is a strategy
to improve fertility too so if you're
good you've won yeah
so the man's corona and if you have a
symmetrical face as a man you're more
likely for your partner to orgasm during
sex not true apparently that women is
that cause or effect I don't know how
they studied that though yeah fair
enough
so yeah I think she I think you're
fairly symmetrical John numbers change
yeah you know you're the same on both
sides
yeah so yeah it was an insurance it was
an insurance policy for me it was trying
to make hold on the phone I brought up
monogamy you start talking about Coronas
and glands and coming and I don't feel
like we made any progress of that I mean
I think so said I'm going to talk about
what mr. von Hippel said that was it
this work right there's different the
different elements of sex is long and
pleasurable that's happening all the
time and everybody's there bonding yeah
so okay okay so so therefore monogamy
isn't the option always in the solution
isn't always it is the solution yeah
that's all I am from evolution isn't yes
it's okay polyamory to me is one of
those things it's like it's like at the
start of this year I was like you know
what I'm gonna do an hour of meditation
everyday that'll be fine three days in
how dry retching on the floor like all
your wife's been DNA the idea that's
presented in this book that's convincing
everyone like I'm sure that it's very
convincing but at some point you've just
got to cut down brass tacks and and be
in a relationship where you're both
sleeping with other people yes and the
and the when we spoke to John real in
yellow he lives with two women the and
he's in a triad of a relationship mm-hmm
and the way he described it it just
sounds like a real that's a forecast as
long as he he is a man who is he's fully
dude he is in a polyamorous relationship
with a lesbian couple and he was like I
understand that this sounds like most
straight men's dreams but trust me
administratively there's a lot going on
black Eve instantly like with a
relationship there is one threat at one
rope yeah
instantly he's just he's like a man
taking 12 dogs from so much so many
intricacies in each of those
relationships yeah to manage all the
time yeah and like by spending one time
more time with one of them you by
definition spending less time with the
other so like if you're Asian ship now
you're already having those feelings of
like I'm working too much on you like
you know the GMO should be in heaven
[ __ ] yeah I'm with part of Warner's
parties he must be so productive to even
just be able to put the time in I think
it's a very effective man fine fair
enough so what was the response to your
video the Y man she has explained my
family guide did you get many comments a
lot of a lot of people a lot of people
replied and I think there was one woman
who said no it's because they're
cheating they're just cheating ourselves
and I mentioned I mentioned that the
word cheat was was in the who's in the
video is in the actual text of the video
is almost impossible to see the video
without reading the word cheat but I
think why man she as explained my family
guy is that just novelty bias isn't it
it doesn't have to be better it just has
to be different and I think a lot of men
and women can kind of agree like it
makes sense both logically and it's been
reflected in experience yeah I think
like although these are stereotypes and
they're always kind of easy for mental
heuristics to you know to jump to quick
conclusions certainly I've seen women
cheat for that reason as well and you
know the the the things were the trends
that we talked about with love versus
respect and sexual novelty and all this
stuff like certainly works the other way
and
I think the way that the female sexual
behavior in the last 20 years has become
progressively more masculine or how it
was stereotypically masculine in the
women now become protagonists and the
the pushers of of sex now in the because
there is less less of a clear gender
role there's less shame and so on around
the whole thing that now cheating
behavior is almost matched as well so
yeah I agree so yep moving forward from
cheating I suppose is how do you end a
relationship
mmm if that's me I'm gonna feel no it's
the like a big poo definitely do you
feel like a big poo Dean Dean doesn't
speak they didn't speak to thee um so
what a self how'd you end a relationship
and ending a relationship generally or
should you when should you end a
relationship that's a great question so
question one when you cheated on or when
you cheat should you end the
relationship a lot I mean it's not gonna
sell at seven quid another twenty no I
think the thing that we brought before
about if you if anybody claims that
someone cheating on them
brought them closer together in the
relationship that chatting [ __ ] it can
only make things worse
I do agree I do agree that there's
probably a couple of people out there
there's some people out there for whom
they may be able to continue as the same
but it's not making your relationship
better days [ __ ] bollocks
well it's removing trust yeah just
destroying though there is it there is
an agreement that neither are you gonna
do that and one of them people is done
unless so we spoke to James Bailey on
the podcast very interesting guy
polyamorous person recently in a
monogamous relationship but just said at
the start look I'm tempted by other
women and this is the case so if we're
gonna if I'm gonna have sex with someone
I'll let you know but this is this is a
you you can as well but let's just over
Garcia started cheating
I suppose it's not because they've set
out the terms yeah
because she thinking is is really just
defined as not you're not adhering to
the terms of the Iranians need to be put
in advance and missus if that's a great
point that we've missed off there the
fact that where do you draw the line
with what isn't isn't cheating and
recently had a discussion with someone
who is regularly on a morning TV show
and she had been on saying that a man
liking other women's photos on Instagram
counts as cheating and I was like fair
enough I don't agree because you are
implying a goal out of that you're
implying a particular desire that he's
trying to achieve by that same argument
it says more about her than it does
about the men to degree but the same
argument would be that among young man
who's looking at another woman in a bar
is exactly the same because that's
pretty much dissenting mmm and but the
the very very gray line of exactly what
isn't isn't cheating like is holding
hands cheating is having a meaningful
conversation with someone cheating don't
hold hands we're cheating you are
cheating on her on Chris
cuz you told us not to oh yeah you've
broken the terms um
yeah like where does the line get drawn
for cheating but I think definitely
should you spoke with someone when you
find out that you've been cheated on I
guess that's a very individual is a
virtual question it depends how much it
matters to you know suppose well is it
if the relationship matters more Hamish
it's you as in like it depends how much
the specific instance of cheating
matters okay we both read my comments of
this stuff and I'd be really interested
if someone could comment if you've ever
been in a relationship where someone's
cheated and you've stayed together and
you were glad that you did come here to
and improve things
hmm that would be I mean that'd be very
surprising cuz I did I stayed with the
girlfriend after she cheated on me and
it was such a mistake I was just like
why did I do that in the first place but
it's just because I I was too like too
clingy I suppose and looking back is
like if I just
taking that as the because because it's
already late stage by the time someone
cheats the bration ship is already
broken by the time it's an alarm going
off as no it's not the problem it's a
lagging alarm as well as yeah it's like
it's so far how much life did you lose
like six months a significant proportion
of your existing so funny it was a life
lost but ya know it could have been life
spent doing other things right not
investing your time in someone else who
didn't deserve it
that's very more time in judgment poor
than your brother at six months so much
in the seismic carotid artery's there so
I think certainly one thing in terms of
like how to when to finish a
relationship the presiding rule that
I've realized over the last few years is
that if you are unhappy in a
relationship and you want to finish it
and you certainly you want to finish it
you should finish it right now and the
reason for that is that not only wasting
your own life are you wasting someone
else's as well mmm
it's respect for yourself and for the
other person isn't it like if you know
that it's not going anywhere
and you can't pluck up the courage to do
it yourself
yep think about the fact that you're
wasting the other person's life too I
mean I mean if you if you need more
motivation than that I'm afraid I can't
give it to you what are the big
objections to doing that
so fear three other people conversation
for fear of making the wrong decision
fear that you'll only realize yeah the
early realizing that you made the wrong
decision later down the line because I
think like any big decision the fear is
I'm going to do this I don't regret it
because if you were here you you were
right it wouldn't be difficult it'd be
like a social conversation I think what
I need to do it it's it's how do I know
because it's it's bad now I've had some
bad experiences I'm not sure it's going
anywhere I'm gonna have this awful
conversation but I might see him or her
with someone else in six months time and
yeah so it's like how do you not just
prolonging the it isn't it it's like I'm
gonna hold on to something just to avoid
that potential feature pain or
discomfort I'm gonna cause myself six
months of mild discomfort and pain I've
made it last a long time
I may be dragged out that I've made I've
made I've known that a relationship has
been over for a very very long time and
then the relationship being over period
has lasted longer than the relationship
not being over period and I mean like
it's just that's my force is momentum
and you just like oh well this is the
news is a Nuri regulated relationship
which is constant kind of unhappiness
and disagreements and arguments and
resentment from you and which destroys
anything beautiful that you did once
have with that person as well like the
way that it works with club nights if we
have a license that goes until 5:00 in
the morning but the club nights waning
at 3:00 we close at 3:00 mm-hmm we don't
let it fizzle out until 5:00 in the
morning because if that happens the few
people that are left at 5:00 in the
morning say oh yeah we're you a foodie
the other night ah it was when we left
it was really [ __ ] really that's so
interesting you do it with club nights
as well so it's a fluid endpoint you go
to say right everyone like it's getting
a bit rubbish the finish on a high
finish you're getting a bit rubbish it's
I think you'll probably get a bit richer
twenty minutes I'm gonna program to it
and they say you do that well like Judy
Murphy does that with training with with
like tumbling specific training always
like when you start to feel good stop
the session today honest I've had it
with training of like I hate Pb Pb Pb
and I'm like this unstoppable and now
fall off a cliff yeah and it's like if
only I just thought you know what end on
a high and you have gotta start to leave
the club Les Mis I think one of the
reasons why so I only just realized this
recently I'm a very empathetic person
and I think that plays into the fact
that I'm empathic is also played on top
of the fact that I don't like upsetting
people and I think one of the other
reasons why in the past struggle to
break up with people was potentially a
lack of self-worth that I was like well
okay now the even though I might not be
happy with this person at least I've got
someone and I'm maybe not worthy of
someone else or maybe I'm not gonna get
someone who's is good or and then
there's there's definitely there's so
much momentum and familiarity and just
level of comfort yeah like all of these
things it's no surprise that finishing
relationships are messy but especially
once you're in it once you're in a point
where like the relationship maybe has
other things associated with it like
where you live or share possessions or
fun hats family pets whatever kids like
the you're not just ending a
relationship you're completely changing
your life yeah associative massive
moving things around is no active and
actually that's one of the biggest
determinants of a depressive episode
there's a shift in your social be in
your life in your circumstance not
necessarily a positive or a negative one
so even if the ending of the
relationship is classed as a positive
shift in your life because it's a big
move something like getting married
moving house any of those things if you
have two or three of those and what go
your likelihood of depression goes up by
quite a lot for that episode so it's you
know the and you pose your brain knows
that that's a big knock and so you end
up holding it off and just thinking
let's just keep the status quo yeah
better the devil you know yeah so I mean
in terms of advice for if you need I
mean we haven't even gotten to this
before and a girl on twit has already
ended a relationship we should [ __ ]
Bravo but the the main thing I want
people to take away from this section is
like if you know that it's not going
anywhere
and you're certain of it then firmly and
compassionately tell the person that
you're with dates over set them down
don't do over text say if it's serious
like if you've been together two months
then [ __ ] like this snapshot them
idolize well then that means Sunday the
story flare this wiper it's the story
yes my book that's why pop to end this
relationship this tree I've got a
message where you find out this way
about what it is yeah so um link tree
but yeah
definitely if you know that it's over
then firmly and compassionately tell the
person that this can't go on anymore
and they'll one the reasons and they'll
want all the rest of it in that scenario
I think it's best again to tell them the
truth I'm on this kind of truth vibe at
the moment and we will do an episode on
my truth is a superpower at some point
in the future but the least that you can
do for someone when you're about to end
a relationship with them is give them
the metrics by which they can improve
themselves for the next relationship I
like that a lot so it's so you when
you're giving them that truth it's it's
because it's doing them a favor but I
think the temptation is either to not
think through the delivery and I've got
a story to associate it with that or if
you're so bitter about it there ends up
just coming across as like like a
pressure cooker and you just unload onto
them when I was 17 18 I broke up with a
girl who I ended up in like a 6 to 7
month relationship with just because I
was basically too passive just in
general in my life and so is the
equivalent of someone like grab me and
put me in the sack in then it's like
right that's it you in relation to
you're my boyfriend now for seven months
and then slowly I was like hang on
like I've had no choice in this so I'm
not really interested in this girl and
yeah this sounds like one of those cold
call people that knock on the door of Oh
a PS and before they realize I've got
300 pounds a month Direct Debit yeah
blazing done I signed up for three
insurances other panels so the panel had
a Google home I don't even use it yeah
so eventually I was like right I'm gonna
have to just in my much further along
this the autism spectrum but I have now
brain I thought what's the best way to
do okay this sounds good right
took her aside just before she died a
person I said at the bus stop at the bus
stop can you look straight down the pipe
for me please and do it
[ __ ] me one yeah
I said Rosie I'm not attracted to you
and I thought it's not clear enough at
all and I just left it and she kind of
looked at me and started crying on her
like okay bye and then that's why I left
because of that pulling aside she missed
her bus she had to wait 40 minutes and I
walked away thinking I think I did that
smoothly let her down gently there and
then realized later on they're
absolutely not sort of three years later
she was still very upset about it and
rightfully so that was a terrible
delivery on all counts but like okay so
the point was like there was a exactly
as he said like that during the whole
six months too passive
not respecting myself or my time or or
her time especially her time because
she's the one who's putting herself on
the line she's the one making herself
vulnerable in that situation really
because it it's it's up to me to be to
reject her or not if someone pursues
somebody you know the it's not a normal
thing to for that just to be like are
okay and there's no doing it on a whim
yeah so exactly as you said
it's bizarrely it's it's so
compassionate to tell someone who likes
you more than you like them that the
relationships over because you you know
that as the relationship continues all
that you're suffering with is an
increase in irritation and perhaps a
waste of time whereas what that person
is doing is entrenching themselves
further into an investment in another
person who doesn't care about them and
the longer that you allow that to go on
than what painful it's going to be when
they decide when when it finally ends
and another thing as well is that I
think a lot of cheating probably occurs
it certainly has done for me in the past
due to me not pulling a trigger on that
so it's like if I decided to say that
the relationship is over when I was
prepared when I knew it was over
I would have cheated less than half the
number of times that I have done so much
of it has occurred after then so that I
mean how many different ways do I want
to be disingenuous to someone who's
putting that like giving me that time
the trouble is though how do you know
yeah I said before how do you know when
you're in that situation because you you
arrive at this point like you know
you're not sat there with your warmup
out thinking like I'm gonna do this next
we'll take Russia tomorrow this is you
know you're you've got this sort of
constant feeling building up of I'm not
necessarily that happy but like you know
maybe things will recover I don't want
them to be in a relationship someone
else I'll just keep for help we've got a
process try deliver it and thought
through it with hindsight doesn't know
but actually at the time you just well I
mean it's the same question is when do
you stop being young and stop being old
yeah like it's not it's a gradual
process and at one point you wake up and
you're old and at one point you wake up
and you're unhappy and the same thing
occurs for that because there is also
this potentially insidious situation
where you are 20 and you're in a
relationship with someone and because of
these beliefs that you have where you
think like I should be like my sex life
should be like this
my personal life should be like this our
social I should be like that you end the
relationship and then 7 8 10
relationships down the line you know
like [ __ ] I should have kept on you
should have to hold out on that
relationship so like gives of your
ideals of what you think a relationship
should be so it's like you're in this
you in this position with someone and
actually they match a lot of what you
would really like about someone for a
long-term partner but you can't see that
at the time because you're searching for
these ideals that you've actually
realized when you're 40 you don't exist
for example just from insta couples that
scene yeah yeah yeah so well that's
that's doing the work on yourself before
you try to make a relationship work this
is why introspective work and
of inquiry and all these sort of things
uncovering your own cognitive biases is
so important if you don't know what you
want you can how the [ __ ] do you expect
the other person to know
but yeah unfortunately for most of the
stuff that we've had so far we've been
able to give a semi autistic framework
to things that's like a set of
guidelines this area of breaking up with
someone the Devils in the details and
the gray area of wine is enough enough
it is a choice which can only be made by
you and the other person and I think
that the only thing that you can do is
once you've made the commitment stick to
it
don't leave the other person with any
lingering sense of hope or potential
that it's going to continue are the
things may get better in the future or
do you just want a break or whatever it
is we all know the the the we all got a
mate who's like been on and off with the
girlfriend for the last ten years and
that never works cut up a botanist yeah
I think I think I do have a framework
laid honest is it a spreadsheet it's not
I can make this spreadsheet subscription
so I think you first have to think this
in exactly the same way is like how you
would approach low carb dieting so like
I can't wait to compare I would break up
with someone to how to approach a local
affiliate so it's X again it's exactly
the same so there are people who are
fine never have a carbohydrate again in
their life okay
I'm not one of those people so when I
choose a diet approach and when I give
my clients diet approaches one of the
first questions is like can you honestly
see yourself sticking to this a year
five years ten years because if it isn't
sustainable at the moment it won't kits
not gonna get better isn't gonna get
probably more difficult and count
releasing so I if you take the standard
relationship probably taking to the enth
degree like you'll move in together and
that comes with lots of complications
you might get married uh comes with
complications might have children family
whatever all those things are complexity
like a LevelUp like an extra thing to
manage so you have to right now think
can I imagine this getting to that point
like do I want this to get to that point
is this person actually an enhancement
do I like spending time with them
because it it definitely should be like
a level up enhancement to your life like
you should feel like a better person I'm
not for me fundamental but I know if you
think there are those things in place
and you're unhappy I would and I've
never done this personally but like
having been in fail relationships and
now in a successful one I think
callate what it is that bothers you
about the person sit down with them and
say these are the things that are
getting to me what about me do you not
like honestly take that list and really
really work on it yourself and if they
aren't receptive to that conversation
then they aren't receptive to making
your work anyway more than likely so
like if you're experiencing problems
chances are they are - because I think
everyone I was terrible at this when I
was younger of like this relationships
not going very well at all what this
person is doing like this is annoying
this is annoying and you like moan about
it with your friends be never consider
like I'm likely just as annoying if
they're just as much of a bastard it's
like but much more blind to our own of
course easier as well as of course your
heads automatic and ingrained yeah so I
think just having in the same way that
you know I like in the relationship to
like a big business of you know I come
it's like the board of Facebook when
there's like the Cambridge on Whittaker
stuff like do they sit and panic and
just all cry and make really rash
decisions and like storm up does one of
them go over to snapchat and and you
know start trying where it's not like I
know this is a down thing like let's
solve this problem like we all want this
to continue being Facebook let's solve
this problem and you've got to have the
same approach and if Mark talked because
there's no clear I work at snapchat then
like Facebook's never going to work yeah
it's [ __ ] so I think that's a good way
that's a good way to look at it and I I
wonder I wonder how many people
would be prepared to write down the list
and then take a list you don't have to
write it down well okay but to present
it to them to present present a list of
the things they're what those include so
if you aren't willing to do that
gather it like there's no there is no
point being in a relationship if you're
not prepared to do what you need to do
to make it work then pull the trigger
and that that advice is the same for
like I want to start my own business I
want to get into shape like all of those
things have an associated level of work
and it's not do I want the outcome like
do I want a really nice relationship I'm
sure you do are you willing to do the
work required can I swallow retain as I
like him I like the idea that you came
up with about projecting forward like
this person I'm with now where Amaya in
six months one year five years ten years
twenty years and can I imagine it
working with them like that
yeah because from there if the answer is
yes sweet maybe do some refining you're
on the right path yeah yeah if the
answer's no you have two choices we have
three but the third on shade the first
choice is that you try and improve
whatever the situation is to go back to
the rocket trajectory analysis like you
and this person are on slightly
different courses and you're beginning
to diverge as time continues that
divergence is going to get worse
you can try and coerce correct yeah
that's one thing yep you can pull your
jack to see mm-hmm and get out of it or
the third one is to allow the courses to
continue to diverge and over time the
small issues will become bigger and by
the time you've reached the moon you're
under thousand miles apart so I would
say in that situation because that it's
just like a second home car market
unfortunately yeah you should go Johnny
go we just as people basically keep
sending me messages saying do you think
that Winston Churchill was a fascist and
I don't know what they mean
you must have mentioned I didn't mention
it was medicine I think it's something I
think it's a reference to Jordan Pizza I
don't know however if you are one of
those people who's sending me a message
saying that Winston Churchill's are
fascist you are fifty four minutes and
thirty seconds into my YouTube watch
time so
thank you very much for your money
through YouTube monetization you're one
of these people that goes on the
internet and looks for things to be
offended by and then gets outraged about
it how I'm gonna subscribe and watch
more of it so I can be more offended
it's like well no one's forcing you to
watch this you bring an are bringing on
buddy I just want you watch time we have
a comment on a video of the day of a guy
saying the video was boring actually I
made this that I've watched it again oh
god yeah it was my sleeping on the floor
video had someone outraged saying forget
sleeping on the floor it's putting meat
into your body and animals products very
and then did another comment which said
I was so outraged by this I had to watch
it twice yeah you like the mention
animal products and where it is all
videos on oh really you don't have it
when the work is the worst thing that
could happen would be for you to share
your opinion with the 13 people that
follow you on Instagram maybe yourself
vulnerable to allathee I would be reward
the level beyond that as when people see
an ad on Facebook and share it and then
say something aggressively like
aggressive to that like Joris like 50
friend that I'm like take EdgeRank you
yep so moving is saying I had a point
it's gonna make by the rocket diverging
okay a second I can't why I pull a
jackass eat because like and let unless
of course you're getting something out
of that relationship outside like maybe
you don't want to be in relationships
along the long term in which case fine
the fact you shows several shame zone
companionship like let's say it's a keep
it to make it very crude let's say the
person that one of the 50 people who
maybe would be perfect in for you is
gonna meet someone in three weeks time
and you never meet them because you're
in this relationship you kind of holding
onto you even though you know it's not
working so and they say shake yourself
off to the crazy thing is what we're
talking about here we keep coming back
to it the the effect are ^ to with
everything everything is squared yeah so
it's like you are in a relationship
which are currently unhappy you could
meet someone in three weeks time that
would be perfect for you but you can't
commit to them because you're in a
relationship and the same is true of the
other person
as well and if you don't want them to
meet someone else then not because of
some kind of bitterness or resentment
then that's a toxic juvenile like like
not only ruining your situation but yous
being selfish than your person for the
sake of IWM to youth like you can't [ __ ]
up your life you can happily [ __ ] up
your life but messing up someone else's
and this is so for me like I'm I'm
perfectly happy suffering the
consequences of my own actions and my
own mistakes within relationships which
have been numerous in the past but one
of the things that I really struggled to
deal with was the upset that caused my
partner like that that is it mutts its
with you for a long time myself it's a
tough pill to swallow an awful lot of
reflection of mindfulness to get over
some of the things that I've done and
it's like it sounds like a [ __ ]
killed someone it happened but again if
you ask someone who's empathetic you're
in this slightly vicious circle of not
wanting to hurt you in a person because
you don't want to hurt them so you don't
pull the trigger on it and then when you
do end up doing it and hurting them then
you've got all of the this extra baggage
of the fact that you dragged it out
absolutely and I've done that myself as
well and you know after I was cheated on
I didn't I mean I wasn't consciously
aware of it at the time that I wasn't
able to fully be present with them and I
was in this kind of really big grudging
six months with them afterwards and I
thought well why have I done this like
why didn't I just she would have been
happier obviously she would have been
happy in the short term should have been
free upset if her because she'd feel
that off I've done this enough caused
this to happen yeah after a month of
surgeon you kind of pretty level of like
a nut I mean nothing that's another
tender des yep here's another here's
another absolute that was a story a
second absolute truism of breaking up
with someone I know that it feels like
either your world or their world are
going to collapse if the other person is
dependent on you you're going to think
[ __ ] I'm gonna destroy them they're
never gonna get over it or if you feel
like you are somehow dependent on them
but you're unhappy or their
relationships abusive or you know it's
not going anywhere you feel like the
microcosm of time that you're in right
now is all that there will ever be and
you can't imagine ever
being happy outside of it but we are
built to adapt as human beings we
literally adapt but that's the only
reason that we've been good we're not as
strong or as fast or as anything else
we're a bit cleverer we can work
together and we can adapt changing
situations like you've seen that thing
about the six-month if someone wins the
lottery or becomes disabled like
paralyzed from the legs down or
something after six months their
subjective ratings of happiness so to
say roughly the same you know she's
absolutely insane I find that so hard
today you're breaking up thing like if
ever everyone's just trying to be happy
and prep an ending relationship is
actually like a step in the right
direction towards that ultimate goal it
was more than likely it was never gonna
happen in that situation anyway you were
unhappy and you should view it as an
opportunity I know it doesn't feel like
one but you should view it as an
opportunity and so the the final bit
which is probably the most difficult is
left of the big boss the last is how do
you get over someone okay so first thing
is realize that no matter how tactfully
you do it even if you're really really
good about it you take them to the side
at the bus stop and you deliver a
perfectly crafted line about the fact
that you're not attracted to them at all
at all you will still get you will still
be the villain among their friends among
their family and there's no way around
that I think even if you were well liked
and that's not necessarily personal is
obviously the Friends of the axe of
wanting are going to want to support
them and as a result demonize you in the
in the stories and everything else and I
think just not to get involved and just
to let them do that and thrash it out
themselves that's that one that's the
presumption that you are the break-up
protagonist to break her up her yeah
breaker upper of the breaker what if you
want what if you are the broken if
you're the broken because this is this
is the scenario I think that most people
fear which is that they care for someone
and that one day they wake up and that
this person say
I don't feel the same about you anymore
there's someone else
this needs to finish and because in some
cases oh thank god
I mean like it's that I mean so here's
again this is my kind of that the main
point that I think guides my particular
emotions in these situations and that
pride in a relationship is such an over
riding overbearing visceral stomach
punching feeling and it for me the loss
of pride it's yeah that you have this
ego and and it's so [ __ ] fragile and
that there's been situations that I've
been in with girls where I haven't
wanted them anymore I don't want them
I'm not bothered about them and I don't
even mind if they're with someone else
like a I'm not attracted to them it
doesn't matter that's all but I still
don't want them to say to me that they
don't want me mm-hmm
it's like I don't want you but I don't
want you to not want me like you're the
dirty penny that's at the bottom of my
bag but you still gotta [ __ ] stay in
my bag and it's such a juvenile
ridiculous way to feel and I think that
the flipping of that power like whether
or not you don't care or whether or you
do care the fact that someone is it's a
comment on you're not enough
it's when someone splits up with you
you're not enough for me you're not
worthy of my time as much as someone
else's you're potentially not even as
worthy of my time as no one is hmm like
it's it's unsurprising that breakups
hurt as much as badly as they do because
it's taken we take it personally when in
reality it probably isn't
it's probably like wait because when you
break up with someone you think it's
because of the other person but it's
because of your feelings and thoughts
and it may even be like stuff with you
rather than the stuff with the other
yeah it's obviously the other person has
a big impact of course but there are the
100% there will be numerous
relationships that are ended because
someone says because someone feels that
they've got some stuff to work on like
look like [ __ ] man I'm just not in the
right place for it at the moment and
they may be being so virtuous is to say
I can't give you what you need I'm gonna
allow you to be happy with someone else
and that really is a very compassionate
thing to say but [ __ ] like if you hear
that get delivered to you just like
mm-hmm but it's dealing with difficult
news and it's how hardly takes something
and that is that is shifting the rest of
your life that you didn't want and try
and make the best of it yeah I think
it's um like it's it's it's not that
different although there is an end point
inside suppose like if you're told that
you have a disease cancer or something
that is like this is you know
immediately like this is gonna affect my
life I didn't want this to happen
you immediately catastrophize something
it's the worst thing possible if all you
can do is control like what I'm gonna do
about it and how I perceive it then
trying to frame this hours like this
relationship has ended but it's the
start of something new I can go find
someone else
yeah actions of like this this is at the
end of this chapter in my life I'm gonna
make myself even better I'm gonna work
on this aspect in my life whatever like
if there are two people and both people
have they're in a relationship of that
dump Tyler cheated on and one person
frames it really positively and just
really doubles down on them in the rest
of their life and the other person spent
six months grieving over the loss of
wistfully thinking both of them are in
the same scenario like neither of their
actions have changed the outcome yeah
but one person's so good point a really
good person treats it as a crisis and
the other opportunity and you and you
can be intense the stoicism thing of
like at all you can control as thoughts
and actions so it breakups the breakup
one of those ways to respond is they're
kind of instant grasping for
looking for someone else often someone
that's not really well-suited but
they're just there the Metis they're
available yeah and that is the mote is
that probably the biggest insult that
you can give to that person because
without them knowing they're just a
filler like a spare you're a substitute
that's come off the bench because the
goalies injured himself mm-hmm so in
terms of effective strategies for
getting over people I've got some fairly
I guess staunch rules with regards to
the way that I have done it in the past
I think that trying to remain friends
with your ex within if it's been a
significantly long relationship I won
that's probably over a year I think that
you should aim to cut contact with them
days everything that is delete the
number tool eat the photos remove them
block them on all social media remove
the phone number for six months and I
think that the reason for that is that
the the way leavener know someone that
did that and they ended up receiving an
email to their like work account or
something it was like the final the last
last Ian of getting through man there's
a this hilarious photo team may be able
to find it of a girlfriend had split
with a boyfriend at university and the
only way that he'd been able to contact
her had been by depositing money into a
bank account with the payment reference
really nice that had the ref that had a
message in it how what should he put as
the amount value though we put like one
P but he did like ten so like a worthy a
would per one be like point of
creativity yeah over that guy's gonna do
well I'm taking about yeah though maybe
not in relationships but in some Silicon
Valley I still yes yes presented with
the problem wasn't you something like
how could it work off your banks like
our minimum transfer is 5 pounds you
my own so yeah
block block and delete everything you
don't want to be reminded of them all of
the stuff that they've got you give it
back to them give it to the charity shop
put it in the bin put it in the Attic do
whatever you need to and then it's
marketplace there's not a market for
it's a nightmare and then I think you
need to spend time with friends Alain de
Botton I will put a link to how to get a
lot of this is derived from Alain de
Botton from the school of life's work
and how to get over someone the video is
fantastic and I think first and foremost
you need to accept the fact that the
relationship is over you need to draw a
very very strong line under it and once
you've accept the fact that it's over
you can then begin to look forward as
opposed to reminiscing and looking back
we need something something to fill the
time that our thoughts have to manifest
and if you can block off the fact of
looking that way you can start to look
that way you need to spend some time
around friends I think being on your own
some time on your own that maybe for
reflection and such like but like call
on your front if you message your
friends a lot of people feel like I've
got no one to turn to I don't have any
friends this than the other
I can't has ever been times where I've
been feeling like down or whatever that
message to you guys I feel like man
having a little bit of a down day within
half an hour like I've got a response
it's like if you call for help and we're
terrible with tell you just shite yeah
like yes I am you know the subject line
urgent like you open the email and it
yeah good man what's happening if I is
happening we can still open me
everything exactly urgent there is a
fire in your butt yeah [ __ ] though so
yeah like spend some time with your
friends I think like go and do something
which distracts you from this situation
you only have so much cognitive capacity
like if you have to go on play [ __ ]
darts or go crazy golf or go to the
cinema or something there will be brief
periods where you're not thinking about
the break-up there has to be like as the
person at the counter says oh have you
got ten pound fifty like if you're
counting the ten pounds fifty I know
this sounds very granular but in some
[Music]
the keshia's mom was called that yeah
yeah yeah I get that but you know they
the slalom small periods little oases of
cognitive break from what you have been
feeling in what you're now feeling
rather than sat in the house just
letting it completely all of our same
words don't overwhelm the same list of
things that make you forget to check
your emails of Chucky fo yeah like go do
is like go like go drive a Lamborghini
around a truck yeah like I guarantee you
you'll not be thinking about your
precise I just [ __ ] terrified yet
exactly like try not spin a hundred
grand car around the corner yeah about
just that yeah and I think as well Alain
de Botton Scott to see I'm not too sure
jump in the North Sea oh god yeah
I mean why if you drunk yeah actually we
cannot say to people who've just been in
America floods jumping off sea scrap
that the North Sea cold shower have a
cold shower yeah don't use ourselves
there just go see you sir come out warm
showers in his house um I think I've got
hot toilet someone pouring hot water
into British uses a kettle for a Thomas
just sits on a Cathal literally and so
yeah I think I think buttons got this
idea where he says that um you should
bore yourself but oh one of the other
opportunities is to bore yourself back
into doing things so he allowed he says
allow yourself as many nights as you
want the cry into a tub of ice cream and
watch as many romantic comes in your
life with your friend until you
literally eyes I am [ __ ] sick of
myself me like okay I'm more there
myself Arthur I think personally for me
and a lot more idiosyncratic than that
so for me what I would try and do is
instantiate some things that I know are
good for me like I still think that I
allow myself to allow the thought loops
to bore themselves out of out of
existence and like I have been in this
particular loop five thousand times
before I do not need to replay it again
I'm less because there's a lot of
psychosocial factors on crying into a
tub of ice cream whilst watching a dark
scream oh I feel about that advice
because you see people especially if
you've got a slightly and in casting
personality and they'll just absolutely
it was looks like the obsession or
personality in them and an intestine
yeah so like if they're just like they
start getting some enjoyment from doing
the the ice cream and watch it and then
that becomes that's the life now and
then yeah you know they say like you
break a habit once and that's it a
mistake break a habit twice and lots of
new habit you've created something new
and suddenly grow you're just going that
hey that's okay I know it's such like I
did it I did a podcast earlier on today
where I talked about how it after a
while of instantiating daily routines
and habits it's a lot and this is both
good and bad unfortunately after a while
it's a lot easier to do them than to not
do them and that works on both sides
yeah like for me to not meditate and not
journal now I'd be like I'd feel like I
was walking with one shoe on and once
she wore the rest of the day horrible
look it's the fact that it's for the
rest of the day it's the real stinking
yeah it's [ __ ] then you miss your
morning routine and before you know it
three months later and you dress that
morning it always does I still feel off
for most of the day five not meditated I
haven't today and like there's a
constant feeling you walk your fingers
through the door earlier and one shows
yeah once you're terrible and there's
advice in way Vesperia man that
currently reading thanks to you two oh
great you reading as well
yeah so a suppo do book i oh yeah great
book david deida
he talks about like when you're in pain
or when you're experiencing something to
like start with your shoulders back and
like just feel it and really acts like
focus on just that so there is an
argument to say that it's really painful
it's really [ __ ] but just like take it
head-on
yeah it's awesome when it hit here's
something to med it
like your life is not lived from the
comfort of your couch like when you look
back on your life in 6070 years time
hopefully you you don't want to think
that you didn't have any experiences as
I watch more Netflix yeah like another
thing to consider is that whatever
you're feeling right now it could be 10
out of 10 pain a chronic globally across
your entire body and you could have lost
everything but in six months time that
will just be a memory like nothing
nothing is going to last forever and
that's one of the few things that you
know so you like right okay I'm feeling
something now I recently did a podcast
an amazing podcast with Alex Hutchinson
he wrote a book called India and in this
what he does is he discusses the
different contributing factors to what
makes an endurance athlete successful
and what he says is that very very good
endurance athletes are able to mindfully
distinguish between the different
elements of discomfort within the body
so it's not just over well it's not pain
and discomfort it he talks about it like
a glass of wine so he says well there's
an undertone of lactic burn I can I'm
getting some notes of breathlessness and
a high heart rate there's a sense of
heat and an discomfort in my head
there's a ringing in my ear there's a
blindness on the side of my eyes and as
opposed to seeing the emotions of
feeling the emotions as a single
nebulous insurmountable problem what you
actually filled them for that component
part and I think that's what you're
talking about there it's sitting with
the discomfort it's like what am I
feeling okay so I've got the the stomach
I can feel the heat rising in my chest
like break it down and you can break
open what is there something the
sensation set in Sam Harris's like
lessons talks about like there's a we
all will have this feeling that at some
point they're like pain or a sensation
or something is absolutely unbearable
to continue but like logically right now
an a moment ago and two moments ago
three months ago you were just
experiencing that and it was fine so
there's nothing different about it yeah
it's about it so I go and do what's
called a Widowmaker
Elizabeth loses 20 reps on back squat
with your 10 rep max and that's that the
only time I could really distantly
remember it happened every time this
decoupling from like I am in this
experience but there's a moment of like
you're always just watching yourself
doing it that sounds impossible by the
way you can keep it on your back until
you've done 10 then you take three or
five deep breaths
rido another edit is you just it
impossible or enter the equivalent that
Alex used in the podcast was I think
it's five by five by five hundred meter
sprint so you go as hard as you can you
run for you run five 500 meters you have
them in one minute rest run again and
then once you've finished you've done
your fifth rep and you're on the floor
dying and panting you'll be in a mega
lactate threshold in that that
particular workout as well your coach
comes over and says you need to do one
more mmm and you're like I can't I could
and you've given it everything on that
fifth round you've given it absolutely
everything you've got hmm but if you
need to get up and you need to go again
you find that you can go again and you
could go again after that
I always find it quite comforting when
I'm training that like I don't need like
not being able to do it I don't need to
worry about that but my body will take
care of that like if the 20 reps squats
like eventually I just can't so I look
like that's taken care of
all I need to do is so relax is continue
this eventually but it's less collapse
for the underneath you guys almost this
like I decide when I give up so I won't
you don't you know your body will take
care yeah and you're gonna be fascinated
by the podcasts I did with Alex's
unbelievable all the way and the the
main thing I'm not gonna give too much
of a spoiler away but the key to
everything he says in endurance and in
mentality within sport is RPE is it
everything
his rate of perceived exertion
everything it's quite it's different
with things that you're actively doing
to yourself I suppose because there
because with grief with breakups and his
grief it's happening to you mmm but this
sense of assertions and Young says
suffering equals pain times resistance
and felt like the holding under the Sun
it's poor thing probably yeah so like
you the amount of resist resisting it
happening to you I suppose like you're
holding on to something there but if
it's something happening to you the more
you're like if you actually just yeah as
you said dial down what are the specific
sensations that I'm feeling you realize
that actually there are a lot smaller
than just like the little atoms and it's
it's you're just seeing this big mass
that you're assuming is huge you realize
that they're just like bubbles and
they're vacuous and side and some Harris
as well talks about like the sensation
in his knee while meditating for a long
time and how it becomes the searing pain
but then it was he kind of zooms in on
it it's like actually I can't
distinguish if it's ecstasy or pain it's
just an intense sensation and this is I
mean this we are we are telling people
who are not broken with the discomfort
is the truth it's a learning experience
and I mean we've all come on in some
ways so here's here's a really nice
thing in ways it isn't really nice
planet you think about Sayer just a nice
thing to think about if you are going
through a breakup or have done or it
going to like what what better of a way
to take ownership of something painful
than to use it for growth hmm yeah I
mean like this is a situation which
would crush a lot of people may even
crush me it feels that those discomfort
and somehow on the other side of this
I've drawn a profit or a positive I mean
[ __ ] like yeah they go that's how a
complete that is how to complete getting
over someone um
so gentlemen thank time very much thank
you very much for your time we will
rinse back anytime we will be back where
I know we're about to do another one
that no one knows we will be back with
relationships 104 which is the long
awaited
Instagram for is this goodness
ready thyselves for the Instagram please
don't be good please do not forget to
press subscribe if you've enjoyed the
episode share it with a friend it would
make us very very happy indeed links to
some of the further reading some of the
other articles that we've mentioned will
be in the show notes below press the
share button press it now please press
it now ok Abidin okay bye
[Music]
you